she had a beautiful soul
she was a great mother
DC Young Fly delivering a touching
speech during Miss Jackie O's
celebration of life service Saturday but
we gotta understand what she did and her
her input and what she did on this Earth
man she made sure our kids was loving
each other
they praying the Wilderness star speaks
about his love for late partner Jackie
who died just over a week ago at the age
of 32 and their three kids together Nova
Nala and Prince Nehemiah I love you Jack
e kids are beautiful man
God granted that strength to have three
DC Praises Jackie for the mother she was
to their children I'm talking about
super great mother and I want our kids
to understand that you had a beautiful
soul
and you didn't leave us you were in
heaven
your spirit is with us you're still here
and we got amazing support system
we got our beautiful support system
because they came out
we love you
everybody in here keep God first
and afterwards DC gave a glimpse into
the service sharing this clip on
Instagram writing sent you off the right
way Mama we miss your presence
can't believe you're in heaven now
knowing you was a blessing the pain we
feel now you're in the clouds
Jackie and DC met in 2015 the same year
he made his first appearance on wild and
out and I
Queen
oh BT Media Group confirmed Jackie's
death on June 1st
loving her a loving friend and beloved
colleague of wild 'n out's cast for Five
Seasons I'm a bit of a rebel when it
comes to this because I'm a little bit
so I don't really do
you think that her impact will forever
be treasured and missed further details
regarding her cause of death have not
been revealed at this time
foreign
[Music]